I love what you two are doing with this
house but what are you gonna do with
five bedrooms you guys are obviously
never having kids
what was that look I did not do a look
you're doing a look right now there's no
have a good fight guys there's so many
kids in foster care and they're having
an orientation alley people who taken
foster kids are really special the kind
of people who volunteer when it's not
even a holiday we don't even volunteer
on a holiday
children are currently in foster care
the county puts these on because they
can match a lot of kids and parents
quickly but they're teenagers okay
maybe's drugs and they watch people
playing video games on YouTube they're
not equipped for any of that
hi this fYI we can all hear you hmm
okay well mingle with the kiddies and
don't give it another thought
bye bye she was cool Lizzy comes with
two younger siblings three kids too much
oh my god
why would you show us that that's wrong
here we make yourself at home because
you're at home
do you like Cooper so more of a Lakers
fan the Clippers are awesome they were
smart for trading Blake Griffin the best
player to the fire department comes okay
he's just another white lady who wants
the job charity orphans to make you feel
good about yourself ten bucks we might
have a little bit of a knack for this oh
I beg to differ
this stuff takes time busy a parent
wanted Lee to all by herself this is
never going to be easy but with some
structure and love you could make your
house
we love you please go away but I'm
pissed you know what I'd like to do
[Music]
all right let me get cool okay
just got my first daddy oh what's up hey
honey can I help you with anything what
are you doing in my phone look at what
this boy texted her Jacob they saw the
picture you separated yeah I'll end your
life right now carrot top we're gonna
call your mom you're going down to tango
what do you think of that shaken my name
is on Jacob what okay okay
you